The joe rogan experience within that
three o'clock I had to go home and change
into white clothes for a year,
not allow for a year,
how to dress him white now for a year.
So for my call is I would just have to
wear white socks and white tee shirt
cause I was a kid.
I can't keep wearing fucking white every
damn I'm ripping shit right so that
your has to grow back.
So when I walk into,
I know there's a ton of
Santeria and La Really,
I don't deal with it at all
because it's all the same thing.
Like everything else in that light.
It's a bunch of white
people and grow up in and,
and there's a hot black guy and they
want to really just suck this day talking
about spirits.
I saw a video today,
I saw a video,
I'm like shame on them.
It's all confused.
It's like those white chicks that suck
that Hindu Dick when they go to hot yoga,
he got big room.
Big Room is a pig you've got is a bunch
of white chicks with hummus flavor and
that mouth from sucking that
he gets to me inside.
He,
you suck that fucking that.
That smells like hummus chips,
you know,
and that's what it is in that way,
like I've been invited to two parties.
First Time I went,
you know who's was in there?
Who fucking the dude
from that playing Edr?
Me.
Fuck played.
Yeah,
mean forest.
Forrest Whitaker.
Really?
The chick that won Miss America
for eating pussy from behind.
The lights in this area are rolling.
Oh,
Vanessa Williams.
It's not my Santeria.
I grew up in a Cuban santare.
You shut your fucking mouth
area because it's a shirt.
My QB.
Is it Mexican influence?
This is white influence.
Oh my God,
let's dance.
Look,
get that.
Look at forest.
It's very watered down.
And look at the guy from Danny Glover.
Forrest Whitaker dressed
up like like fucking monks.
That's crazy.
Don't do.
I don't pop the plate.
I came up hilarious.
I came up under the very strict,
shut your mouth.
Nobody needs to know
your fucking business.
What
are these two?
The only thing,
the role
and then I want to,
I do have a question.
You know,
you might have an answer.
What did you have a half of spray?
I had one spray.
Good enough.
Okay.
Alright,
we're in.
What was the other
question that you think,
why am I asking you this?
But I think you might have an answer.
So,
but I'm being totally honest.
I exhausted from dealing with like a,
it's not like it's a big deal,
but it's like the first time you,
whether you can admit
major things in your life.
Like,
oh I have a drinking problem,
but would be stupid little things.
Yeah,
mine is eating.
I'm like,
I'm exhausted from doing it the wrong
way and everything comes back to me for
self control.
So when people want to
tell me about a diet,
I don't,
it's not portions.
I know what portions are.
I just,
I want to eat more.
So it's all down to how do
I fucking get self control?
I have zero.
I mean,
if I'm not going to call
it zero self control,
then I don't know what the
hell I'm going to call it.
But as you are hard for me,
you're not,
you're hard on yourself.
I think you have self control.
Todd,
I think you're a wonderful man,
but you're,
you're hilarious.
And one of the reasons why you're
hilarious is because you're so,
you're free,
you're impulsive and that sort of debt,
it's very difficult for that to
lend itself to dietary discipline.
It's like,
how can I eat it?
Fuck it.
I'll just fucking eat it.
Right.
That's you.
But it's also part of what makes
you such a hilarious comic.
It's like you have these impulses.
It makes me feel better.
You don't want split the difference,
at least with what you're saying.
You don't want this comfort
and you want to have fun.
And it's like,
it's right there.
They want to,
I want to eat that food.
Fuck it.
I thought of me like picture me at the,
at the uh,
cancer shoving cheesecake Uma in my mouth
and my friends are like looking at me
like Todd and I go,
okay,
Joe Rogan said that because I'm creative.
Good.
I see whatever I want.
He said,
go listen to his podcast.
He said that I should eat.
He calls Joe Rogan and you can go listen.
He said,
clear off the mini bar before
you get in your hotel beds,
even if you're not really
hungry because I'm creative.
Okay.
So I don't have control over this.
Do you want to like meet in the middle of,
you're like,
okay,
it's legal,
but you can't name it.
Well,
do you think that you
could fuck a real doll?
I mean,
you definitely could if you had to,
but would that be something
you'd be interested in?
I think I couldn't stop laughing at how
ridiculous this situation where I would
just jerk off and think about things.
I fucked a,
we had as a sponsor,
a flush left side.
I've had a flashlight forever.
Flash light.
It's very utilitarian.
You're not confusing yourself.
Nobody's ever said that
one before describing.
She's the girl of my dreams.
I've never even,
I've never used it.
I've had it forever.
I've never even thought about it.
I couldn't guess why I
would want to use it.
Seems Weird.
It's weird.
It feels good though.
Does it way better than jerking
off and engulfs your whole Dick.
Yeah,
and you put it in warm water and you
get it like to a temperature of a body
and you're like,
it's real.
Somehow or another.
This is like a portal,
like this tube is a
portal to another woman,
another dementia,
but all you can get out of
her vagina and just hold it.
That's it.
Feels real.
The name of this dimension
is called awesome.
Do you jerk off with a fleshlight
or do you hold it and fuck it?
No,
he jerked out.
You jerk off of this.
You jerked me off of the flashlight.
Yeah,
but that was for sure.
That was on camera behind the curt green.
This interview.
We did this on the podcast.
I swear to God,
he jerking off with the
flashlight producer.
No,
I couldn't get hard.
It was a female comic.
Whoa.
What's that about?
Is that a fuck real?
That's a real doctor.
Real though.
They're getting pretty good man.
They were redhead though,
was a documentary on Netflix about people
fucking sex robots really have come
far because there are people who fall in
love with these sex robots and it looks
like the fucking taxi driver Johnny
on the spot from total recall.
It's like this is crazy.
Like animatronic Chuckie cheese,
bass player.
It's kind of get to a point where it can
totally mimic you and he's going to get
to a point where it really
is like blade runner.
Is that what they are now?
Yeah,
that's it.
I thought about buying a
dude one to do Jujitsu with
that was going to order one.
Clearly no Jake and a sealed bottle.
That proportions are perfect
because I have a dog.
Well it's this bubba dummy
the practice submissions on,
but it's super stiff.
It's like this,
but he beat you.
You basically can drill the moves,
but it's not the same as drill in
and on an anatomically correct body.
If you had an AMA anatomically
correct body to practice Jujitsu on,
you'd get some fucking tight moves.
But that can wait till the day when
you're announcing for robot fights.
No,
I a zero interest.
There's nothing at stake
if they live or die.
It doesn't matter.
The,
the whole thing about fighting is that
there's some horrible gigantic thing at
stake.
You can fuck one though.
Yeah.
You fuck with him?
I watch him fight.
Would you watch two robots?
Fuck.
That's how it goes.
It's weird.
Yeah man.
Thank you for,
do we need to say anything more
about the Brennan shop thing?
Did we cover it up enough man,
as far as it goes,
it's just like,
that's what I'm saying.
We,
we like,
we need to talk him and he you,
you know?
Yeah.
So it's a weird situation for me because
I love the guy and he's one of my best
friends and also I can't defend what
he said cause it doesn't totally make
sense.
Yeah.
And so like what I'm saying,
when I said he talks too much,
I do too.
I say stupid shit.
I don't mean to say stupid shit.
I don't say that stupid.
Um,
I didn't say that thing.
I wouldn't say it like that.
Yeah.
But sometimes you say things,
you don't even know why
the fuck you're saying it.
You know?
And a lot of it also was lost,
like just ranting.
Like you,
you're going to these rants and you say
shit and then you like see if you can
back it up once you set it.
Yeah.
Like just don't revisit dumb shit.
That's like,
it was insensitive.
It didn't make sense and it was
insensitive and I bet he regrets it.
Well,
I mean,
I don't know.
That's an assumption we're making,
right?
Yeah.
I'm glad I know the guy.
That's why I'm saying it.
Yeah.
He's not a bad guy by any
stretch of the imagination.
He's awesome.
Um,
I'm not a of the of the,
I'm not the guy saying like,
here are racist for saying this.
Like,
um,
like my,
my thing is when you're talking about the,
the first,
the initial part of it,
and I conveyed this to him,
you know,
was you're saying me or my brother or
my sister are good enough to be here.
So like that's,
that's disrespectful because I fully
believe that we all are and that,
that,
so that part and he apologized
for that and we're cool there,
you know,
and then,
then,
then why are you,
why are you talking about like,
this is what I see in
myself because no dog,
that's not,
that's not how it is.
No,
no,
you're not,
you're not a psychologist,
not a psychiatrist.
You have no qualifications to,
to speak on my state.
Like,
like,
let's just weird too
that you guys haven't,
uh hmm.
I don't know.
I think sometimes someone says something
instead of just straight up saying they
fucked up.
They say I fucked up.
But yeah,
you know,
I fucking up.
But you know,
he's,
his issue is because of this or you know,
something else is going on with him.
It's making him react this way.
Yeah.
I'm more concerned with his pants.
Those shred it up pants and wears those
disturbing way more than what he said.
I can't,
can't defend neither one.
Yeah.
I'm just don't wear women's pants.
I don't think they're women's.
They just holding them.
They hold it on cause it back.
We went through that at the beginning
of the show and they have holding them.
It depends on how many holes,
right?
Like depends on like,
well,
if you earn those holes,
like if you work construction,
you got like a real hole.
Yeah.
You get you,
you get your pad snagged on it.
Yeah.
You gotta do what you gotta do.
You know,
if you're a farmer,
you got like real Barb
wire holes and your pants.
That's a different animal,
you know,
that's,
that's okay.
You earn those holes.
You wore your jeans out.
They started ripping in places.
Okay,
okay.
You can't afford to buy some new ones.
Yeah.
But if you paid a lot of mine for
pants that are already fucked up,
you saw that shit in a magazine somewhere.
That's what bothers me about Brendan
fucking pants.
Okay.